[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN BUTMAN: I've
always been fascinated
with the founding of America.
I'm a New Englander.
I live in Maine right now
but I lived in Massachusetts
for a long time.
So maybe when you
live in New England,
the founding of America
is something you're
supposed to be interested in.
New England is where
it all began, right?
This is the home of the iconic
founders of America-- none
other than the famous Pilgrims.
But even though
I've been fascinated
with the founding of America,
I have been less fascinated
with the Pilgrim's story.
I've actually always been
a little bit put off by it.
There's something about it that
is not quite believable to me.
A little too perfect, maybe
a little too sanctimonious
or something.
Well, it turns out that I
was right about that story.
There is something
wrong with it.
In fact, virtually everything
is wrong with this story.
The Pilgrims of course,
were not the first Europeans
to settle in America.
They did not come here
for religious freedom,
as we often-think.
They came here, primarily,
for economic reasons--
for jobs.
They were not
totally independent.
They were funded by a
joint stock company.
So they had investors,
they had to turn a profit,
and they had a lot of debt.
So I think this
particular founding myth
is due for a little rethink.
And that's the
subject of our book
that I wrote with my
co-author, Simon Target.
The reason for that is, I think
the real reason the accurate
version is more interesting.
And I also think that it can
give us a useful perspective
on where we are right now.
So let me give you the
thesis in a nutshell.
The European founding of
America began some 70 years
before the Pilgrims
arrived on Cape Cod.
It was driven, not
by the Pilgrims,
but by an amazing group of
English businesspeople-- three
generations of them.
Many of them knew each other.
Many of them were related
over generations--
father, son, grandson.
And they teamed up with an
amazing bunch of people,
including politicians,
intellectuals, writers,
navigators, mariners, and
assorted other kinds of people.
The purpose was primarily
profit, finding America.
There was, of course, a
bit of idealism, glory,
self-promotion, social purpose,
and national pride thrown
in but profit was number one.
So I like to put it this
way-- the simplest way
to think about it, to me,
is America was perhaps
the biggest, longest,
most complicated
business startup of all time.
But the story's never
really been told that way.
So that's the story I
want to tell you today.
So it begins in
1515, not in 1620.
Begins in England.
At that time, England
was a very small player
on the margin of Europe.
And we have to go back
to 1492 to understand
that after Columbus discovered
there was a lot of territory
that they didn't know about,
the Spain and Portugal were
the dominant powers and they
both wanted the New World.
So to avoid conflict,
Pope Alexander VI
divided the world in half.
The Treaty of Tordesillas, which
is this line that you see--
Where's my little button?
Here we go.
--right there.
So this line.
Everything to the east was
given to Portugal to develop
and everything to
the west Spain got.
Why the pope felt he
had authority to divide
the world is
another whole topic.
So Spain quickly pushed into
the West Indies, Mexico,
and South America.
They plundered, they
extracted precious metals
at a ferocious rate.
Portugal pioneered the largest
and richest market on Earth
at the time, which
was of course China.
You see it right there,
it says Cathay, which
is how they talked about China.
But England was in crisis mode.
It was a time of great
political turmoil.
They had a weak, 14-year-old
monarch named Edward VI.
And he was surrounded by lots
of counselors who were jostling
for position and power.
There was tremendous
wealth disparity
which led to rioting in the
streets and in the fields.
And business was terrible.
England had one major
product, which was wool--
raw wool and woolen cloth.
And their major market
was continental Europe.
But for many reasons
I can't go in to,
the bottom fell out of the
cloth market in the 1550s.
Demand fell, prices dropped,
business was terrible,
profits went down.
The crown tried many
solutions none of them worked.
England was in a really dire
economic situation, almost
an existential crisis.
They needed a big solution
and the private sector
stepped up because the
crown could not do it.
A group of merchants
started thinking very big.
Their goal was to
boost the economy
and they hoped to
save the country.
One of the key movers was
this fellow named John Dudley.
And he assembled
a group of what he
called grave citizens, the
serious citizens as they
called themselves.
And devised an audacious
solution to England's woes--
they were going to
look beyond continental
Europe for a new market.
A new place to sell their cloth.
The first target
was the Far East.
And that meant India.
This is Calicut, which on
the West Coast, the Malabar
Coast of India, and it's
kind of the gateway to China.
And then on to China.
There in China, they
were going to do what
the Portuguese had long done--
they would trade their cloth for
the fantastic and endless goods
that China offered.
Mostly spices, which they used
for cooking and for medicine
and specialty cloth such as
silk, which England did not
make.
They would bring them home
and they would sell them
in to continental markets.
This is my favorite
shot of Antwerp
at the time, which
was the biggest,
most bustling city in Europe
and a great marketplace.
And they would
gradually, the English
would develop a Far East trade.
But this was really
moonshot territory.
They had no experience, the
English in trade on this level.
They'd never been this far away.
They'd basically be
trudging back and forth
to the continent
with their cloth.
The farthest away they traveled
was to Iceland and Ireland
to fish.
And those were just
short haul voyages.
And here we see fish
stuffed into fish.
But they faced this
serious barrier
to entry-- the Tordesillas line
and the trade routes dominated
by the Portuguese
and the Spanish.
So to pull off this
moonshot venture
they had to come up
with a new approach.
They needed capital,
they needed organization,
they needed
knowledge, technology,
they had to develop everything.
So first, they invented a
new organizational form--
the joint-stock company.
And it was perhaps the first in
the world, certainly the first
of its kind in England.
And they gave it a
very handy name--
the Mysterie, Company,
and Fellowship
of Merchant Adventurers
for the Discovery
of Regions, Dominion's,
Islands, and Places Unknown.
Fits easily on a business card.
They called it the Mysterie.
The Mysterie is
not quite as cool
a name as it sounds because
it actually means mastery as
opposed to something secretive.
They raised capital.
Because the venture is
so risky and the return
was so uncertain,
no single investor
or even a group
of angel investors
could really come up with
the kind of cash they needed.
And no insurance company
wanted to underwrite this.
There were insurance
companies at the time
but no one was going
to underwrite this.
So the Mysterie offered
shares at 25 pounds each,
promoting the voyage as
a national enterprise.
And 240 investors bought
in to this completely
high-risk, crazy idea raising
a total of 6,000 pounds.
So then to figure
out how to get around
this problem of the trade
routes and the Portuguese
and the dividing
line, they brought
in the most famous
navigator of the day--
Sebastian Cabot.
They essentially
poached him from Spain.
He'd been working in
Spain for many years
as the head of the government
office that oversaw
all Spanish overseas activity.
Now, Cabot had a secret map.
He was very proud of this.
And it revealed an
improbable solution
to the problem of the
route to the Far East.
Cabot told John Dudley and
his other Mysterie merchants
that they could
sail north and there
they would find
an open waterway.
A passage that would take
them to China and they
could avoid encroaching on
the Spanish or the Portuguese.
So they're all down here.
They can either go east
or they could go west
and they would end up in China.
Well, the merchants
bought this idea.
No one had ever been
through the passage.
They had no assurance
that it could be done.
The problem was that the
English ships of the day
had no capacity to sail
that long that far north
in those difficult conditions.
It was very cold of course.
This is actually a
little later ship--
that's Queen Elizabeth
sitting on the poop there.
The poop deck.
So they invested the capital,
the 6,000 pounds in building
three brand new ships.
They had all the
latest features.
They had all the latest
navigational instruments.
And they had larger
capacity in the holds
to bring back all those
great Chinese goods.
But they had very little
idea what they needed--
how to go about managing and
leading a venture like this.
Because their leadership
models were basically
from the military
and from the court.
And this was very different.
So they didn't know
what to choose.
They chose one Hugh Willoughby
to lead this expedition.
He had absolutely no
experience on the sea.
And he was just
from a good family
and they thought he would be OK.
The management was from
fishing expeditions,
which were again, short haul.
But none of these
methods really applied
to this sort of blue sky,
blue ocean crazy adventure.
So they engaged another fellow
named Richard Chancellor,
there's no picture of him.
Who was just a
regular person but he
had experience as a navigator.
So with Sebastian
Cabot's council
they put together a kind of
business plan, an employee
handbook, and
performance guidelines
and they called them ordinances.
And this is the beginning
of the ordinances.
So these were basically rules
for running this crazy venture.
The first one I think
is really touching.
It says that all ventures
should be quote, "Knit
and according in unity, love,
conformity and obedience."
Essentially teamwork.
Another ordinance
directed them to keep
careful records of the voyage--
write everything down.
The beginning of the
learning organization.
The men were instructed
not to laugh or deride
any foreign people they might
meet, not to abuse women,
and not to resort to violence.
So again, this is
sort of beginning
of respect for diversity,
which they were not used to.
And then, perhaps
most important, Cabot
urged them never to give up.
Never to give up until their
mission shall be accomplished
so far forth as
possibility and life of men
may serve or extend.
So commitment perseverance
was important.
Willingness to push
through failure.
Now, I said profit
was not the only goal.
It was a big one but you
know, it never really
is in any kind of
venture like this.
The English merchants
had some idealism.
They had a higher purpose, a
kind of vision, if you will.
And given the mess of
English society at the time,
and the government
and the economy,
the vision was pretty
big and idealistic-- it
was of a more perfect society.
And it largely came
from a book, "Utopia."
So "Utopia" was published
originally in 1516 in Latin.
But it came out-- was
published, especially again,
this time in English
just as The Mysterie was
organizing this trip to China.
Now, if you've read it recently
it's a pretty interesting book.
I've read it a few times.
It describes this
more perfect society
with quite a lot of detail.
And in this society, men and
women are completely equal.
Women could serve as soldiers,
they can serve as priests.
No one is ever overworked,
six hours tops per day.
That's all that's allowed.
1/7 of all income
goes to the poor.
Everyone has a voice in society.
There's relative equality.
There are no lawyers at all.
War is frowned upon.
And my favorite one is
before you get married,
the partners are required
to get a good look at one
another naked.
So the English kind of
translated the idea of "Utopia"
into a simpler idea, which
they called Commonwealth.
So the fleet of three ships
set sail in 1553, May 20.
And everybody
turned out to watch.
This was a national occasion.
But things did
not go as planned.
The northern passage
could not be found.
The ships got separated.
Two of the ships were lost.
But one of the ships led by the
navigator, Richard Chancellor,
did get as far as the White Sea.
So it's a little hard to
see because that map is not
very accurate.
But basically they looped
over and got as far as that.
They wanted to go there
but they couldn't.
However, they left
the ship there.
They negotiated with the
Russians on the ground
and they traveled to Moscow.
This is how Moscow
looked at the time.
And there they talked
their way into court.
They had a letter from the
King and they got an audience
with Ivan VI, later known
as Ivan the Terrible.
And basically they
negotiated terms with Ivan
and said, let's
open trade relations
between Russia and England.
And they did.
And there had been no trade
between England and Russia
for 500 years.
So it was not a big and
lucrative market, Russia,
but it gave the English
a lot of confidence
that we can get outside
continental Europe,
and to help them be
flexible, to see failure
as learning not as
shame, and to pivot.
So we can't get to China,
we'll go to Russia, that'll do.
So now we skip ahead a
couple decades to 1575.
There's a lot of stuff going on
that I can't obviously cover.
Just going to give
you the highlights
of the move towards America.
Knowledge of the world was
improving at this time.
Mapping was getting better.
More was known about America.
England was still struggling
with its business problems.
So in that year another
company was set up
to try again for China,
called the Cathay Company.
China.
It too was led by businessmen
and funded by them.
Four merchants put
in seed funding.
They got another 18
investors to put in money
and they engaged this fellow,
Martin Frobisher, as commander.
He had a lot of
experience at sea
so they sort of learned
you need to put somebody
who knows what they're
doing, that has the skills
to run the voyage.
Again, the plan was to
sail north for China
but this time they're
going to go Northwest.
You can see, this
is America here.
And these are all the islands.
Here's Greenland
and here's Iceland.
And there's Ireland and England.
And they're going
to go through here
and find their way west
and then on to China.
Plus, there was a new
wrinkle, which they added.
And that was that
they thought let's
set up a little trading
post somewhere in America.
And their idea
was that they knew
there were lots of Indians
in America and it was cold.
And they thought, we could
sell our nice woolen cloth
to Indians.
They will need blankets.
They will need clothing.
They're probably cold.
They also felt that
a post here could
be a good sort of stopping point
for ships going on to China
and they could service them.
So after much
hardship, Frobisher
got as far as a little island.
We're not exactly
sure where it was
but you can see right
there, Frobisher's Straits.
That's where he intended to
go, somewhere around here.
And he was pretty certain
he'd identify the opening
to the Northwest Passage.
But the crew was not happy.
At this time, crews
are very badly paid.
They did not invest
so they had no share.
They had no stake in the action.
Conditions on-board
ship were terrible.
They had no decision
making authority.
It was all top down.
So all they could do
was threaten mutiny,
which is exactly what they did.
Frobisher though said,
I'm not returning home
without proof of how
far we've gotten.
Because when you get back
home, you have to demonstrate.
There's no photographs.
So they had had a
number of engagements
with Indians, the Inuit.
And they did what English began
to do with some regularity--
they captured one Inuit.
This is one they
actually took later
but you can see this
is a woman and she's
got her baby with her.
They also picked up some rock.
Now, why exactly
they picked up rock--
it's hard to say but they did.
And this rock ended up
changing everything.
The story goes that the
wife of one of the investors
threw some rock into the fire,
it started to glisten and glow.
And they said, oh, my
god, we found gold.
So word got out.
Suddenly, there's a national
furor that we have found gold.
Even Queen Elizabeth who was
naturally quite skeptical
about this kind of
venture got involved.
She invested money
in a second voyage.
And the English were
so excited about gold
because it was precious
metal that had helped
Spain transform themselves.
They've been bringing back
mountains of gold and silver
from the New World since--
well, since 1545
was their big find.
So if England could find
a gold mine in America,
perhaps they could
really challenge Spain.
And this is the gold mine that
Spain got most of their silver
from in Peru.
They basically abandoned
the Northwest Passage idea
and the whole idea of setting
up a trading operation.
And merchants and
investors started
to put money into
a second voyage
to go bring back more rock.
Two more voyages went out.
Tons of rock were brought back.
They brought in
specialist metallurgists.
Metallurgy and assaying
was quite true to the time.
And in the end, tons
of rock turned out
to be totally worthless.
It was Fool's Gold.
Investor's lost all their money.
It was a national embarrassment.
Spain was watching
and laughing at them.
The rock ended up being used to
pave roads and to build walls.
But the business community,
again based in London,
learned some valuable lessons.
First, do not chase
the success of others.
And they almost
completely abandoned
the idea of matching Spain
and finding precious metals
in America.
They also realized that the
China plan was not working,
they wanted to get rid of that.
And they had evidence that
America was very large
and had great resources.
And one of the greatest
resource of all was land.
So we leap ahead to 1583.
And now the English
ventures to America
start to come a little faster.
Sir Humphrey Gilbert is our
next featured character.
He had a particularly
audacious plan,
even more so than
sailing to China.
He imagined a vast
American colony.
Not just a trading post but
a sustainable, long-term
investment in infrastructure
and a business operation.
He realized that
America probably
had millions of acres of land.
Because they knew the position
of the East Coast and the West
Coast.
They didn't know
exactly what was
in between but they knew there
was a long way in between.
So Gilbert was
granted the rights
from Queen Elizabeth I
to discover and claim
new territories in
America and develop them
as he saw fit basically.
He attracted many
investors by offering them
large parcels of land.
In fact, he offered them as
many as three million acres
to invest.
All of England only
contains 30 million acres.
So three million acres sounds
like a pretty good deal.
He formed another new company.
Put together a
syndicate of investors
and he called it The
Merchant Adventures
With Humphrey Gilbert, which has
a little Las Vegas sound to me.
He was something of
a dreamer though.
And he had very
little experience
as a leader and no
skills as a commander.
Indeed, Elizabeth, who
knew him very well,
begged him not to
go on this trip.
She said, you are not
of good hap by sea.
You're not good on the ocean.
But he set sail anyway
with five ships.
In 1533 he hit very bad
weather and he ended up
in Newfoundland, which is
not where he planned to go.
So he goes here and
he ends up over here.
But he said, fine.
It's an international
fishing ground.
He claimed Newfoundland
for England.
You can imagine he's
going ashore and saying
this is our land now.
And there are fishermen
from all around the world.
He also declared to them that
anybody fishing in Newfoundland
would have to pay England a duty
on all the fish that they took.
The fishermen all agreed
knowing that this was completely
unenforceable, which it was.
Gilbert then sailed south
heading for America.
Hit another storm and
he sank and he drowned.
And that was the end
of that adventure.
However, although he
failed almost completely,
he fundamentally changed
the English approach
to New World commerce.
So in 1585, after
Gilbert's death,
Elizabeth transferred the
American development rights
to Sir Walter Raleigh, the
well-known Sir Walter Raleigh.
And he carried on
with Gilbert's idea.
He realized that to create a
sustainable, long-term, on-site
business venture they needed
the full range of human skills.
They needed all the crafts.
They needed women.
They needed families.
They needed the community--
diversity of talent.
This is the first
time they've really
started to think this way--
Commonwealth.
He also realized that
the settlers would have
to own property themselves.
They had to have a
stake in the action.
They had to have skin
in the game themselves.
So the plan was very good.
The execution was not so good.
They chose a very poor site--
a swampy island called Roanoke
just off the coast
of North Carolina.
Although they struggled
on for five years
with three resupplies,
it never took off.
And finally in 1580, the
colonists disappeared.
We still don't know
what happened to them.
Now, while the English ventures
were learning all this stuff
about leadership
and management they
were also learning about
one other business activity.
And that is marketing.
They realized they
needed to reach out
beyond the group
of just investors.
They wanted a broad
base of support
and they needed a
really great story.
So they began with
their own adventure.
They actually took a water
colorist, named John White,
with them and he
made a whole series
of beautiful paintings of Indian
life and of the territory.
This is an Indian village.
They brought them back
and published them.
And English people thought,
this looks pretty nice.
America could be OK.
And there are many images
of the Indians themselves.
And they thought, oh, it's
just a family having dinner?
That looks edible to me.
They felt, OK, these
people can be friendly.
And then, in 1589, a writer,
named Richard Hakluyt,
published an
enormous book called
"The Principle Navigations and
Voyages of the English Nation,"
which was the first
book that really told
the story of English discovery.
And it was a huge hit.
And it gave the English a
whole new idea of themselves.
They said oh, we can do this.
We can be like Spain.
We can go out there and succeed.
And from then on every venture
had pamphlets and marketing
materials.
So you can see these development
efforts basically all
failing for 50 years.
And it sometimes
takes a moment when
conditions change when suddenly
something can take off.
So this is the case with
American development.
So after 1600, a
number things changed.
First of all, there
was a great deal
of knowledge about the
New World by this time,
and America in particular.
Maps were much more detailed.
So you can see that America
is really starting to fill in.
You get a real sense
of what it looks like.
And along the East Coast in
particular, it's quite detailed
and along the West
Coast as well.
That's because there
a lot of ships,
a lot of people
gathering information--
basically crowdsourcing
information about the coast.
And they understood the
routes to go back and forth.
And then the major
thing that happened
was that Queen Elizabeth died
and King James took over.
And Elizabeth had never been
big on American development
but James was interested.
And he immediately brokered
a peace with Spain.
This, you see, is the
peace negotiations
going on between the
English and the Spanish.
Suddenly, the American
market opened up
because the treaty said
it's OK, we can share.
We can go into
each other's ports
and so there was no
longer this restriction
against the Americans
sailing to America.
So another new company
was quickly formed, called
the Virginia Company.
At that time, the entire
East Coast of America
was known as Virginia.
And the company
formed two groups
each one putting together
an American mission.
This is 1606.
They were very different
and the differences
make it really
clear which one had
learned the lessons of the past
50 years and which one had not.
So the first one, led by
Raleigh Gilbert, sailed north.
They sailed to Maine and
established a settlement
on the Sagadahoc River,
now known as the Kennebec.
But it was very
military in character.
The plan was to build a fort.
Here's the plan for the fort.
So they were thinking about
military and about armaments.
It was underfunded.
The leadership was
again, not skilled.
The participants had no voice.
They had no share in the action.
There was no clear
business plan.
This settlement, known as
the Sagadahoc Settlement,
just made it through
the first winter
and then they all went home.
The second group,
led by Thomas Smith,
organized a venture to
the Southern Coast, which
became known as Jamestown.
And it was very well-funded.
It had good organization.
It had strong leadership.
There was a business plan.
They developed a code
of law, the first code
of law developed in America.
They established
a governing body
called the House of
Burgesses, which is
self-representive government.
Private ownership
of land was possible
and there was kind of a
sense of shared purpose.
It was hardly a utopia but it
was much closer to Commonwealth
than what they were
used to in England.
So that brings us
back to our Pilgrims.
Pilgrims arrive on
Cape Cod in 1620.
This is 14 years
after Jamestown.
And that was a
social experiment.
They are to be admired.
But as a business
venture, not so much.
They struggled along
for many years.
Other settlements
came in and started
to succeed, especially the
Massachusetts Bay Company.
The Pilgrims were never
particularly profitable
for themselves or
for their investors.
In fact, they did not
earn out, or pay back,
their loan until 1647.
27 years after they sailed,
which I don't think most VCs
would be too happy with today.
But the Pilgrims still
get all the attention.
So why is that?
If you look at this, the
Oxford English Dictionary,
this is today--
defines the Pilgrim
Fathers as the group
of English Puritans,
which is not correct,
who set up the colony of
Plymouth, Massachusetts
and are regarded as the
founders of the United States.
Not just America, but
the United States.
So the OED has it
completely wrong.
So why is this?
Why did the Pilgrims
become the myth
and why did Jamestown
not or some other group?
And the answer is it
was no accident at all.
The Pilgrims actually
only attained
this kind of status as a myth
until the mid 19th century
during the pre Civil War days.
And they became the symbol
of America's good values
of inclusion and
tolerance and the south
became the symbol,
Jamestown in particular,
as America's bad values,
intolerance, and particularly
slavery.
So a whole group of Northeastern
intellectuals and others
mythified the Pilgrims.
This is Daniel Webster.
And he mythisized Pilgrims as
the quintessential Americans.
Then we had some
foreigners come along--
this is Alexis de Tocqueville,
the famous Frenchman
who toured America.
And he wrote about the Pilgrims.
And I'll just read
you what he wrote.
He said, the pilgrims did
not travel to the New World
in hope of improving
this situation
or enhancing their wealth.
They tore themselves
away from the pleasures
of home in obedience to a
purely intellectual need.
Again, completely wrong.
Then, we had songs written--
"My Country 'Tis of Thee," every
third grade student knows this.
Land where my fathers died,
land of the Pilgrims pride.
There were big best sellers.
Henry Wadsworth Longfellow
wrote a poem to Miles Standish.
And he laid on the adjectives.
The Pilgrims were patient,
they were courageous,
they were simple,
they were modest,
they were tender, trusting,
noble, and generous, et cetera.
And then came the big clincher.
Now this woman is Sarah Hale,
she was a magazine editor.
And she strongly believed
that Thanksgiving,
which the pilgrims had held in
1621, the first Thanksgiving,
should become a
national holiday.
She saw it as a symbol of
unity and coming together
of all people in America.
She wrote a succession of
presidents-- five presidents.
She wrote finally to
President Lincoln.
And this is the letter
that she wrote to Lincoln.
And begging him and entreating
him to declare Thanksgiving
as a national holiday.
And Lincoln finally
in 1863, in the middle
of the Civil War with a country
torn apart, did exactly that.
He proclaimed it a
national holiday hoping
to bring Americans together.
And really since
then, Thanksgiving Day
has been seen as a day of unity,
of family, of American values.
And is fittingly surrounded
by commerce of course.
There have been plenty of
dissenters to Thanksgiving.
Of course, you've
got Indians who
did not see it that
way who described it
as a day of mourning.
Catholics were
not happy with it,
they saw it as a
Protestant holiday.
And the South was
not too thrilled
to be seen as the part of the
country with the bad values.
But the Pilgrims have
really been riding the wave
of Thanksgiving ever since.
And in a sense, I
think, of the Pilgrims
as America's first and
most enduring brand.
So if you are willing to
entertain the idea of America
as a big business
startup, then perhaps we
can take the metaphor
one step further
and think about what that
means of what we are today.
And you could say
that we are a sort
of the equivalent of a big,
established company in a very
mature market.
And if you accept that, then we
know the risks of big companies
in established mature markets.
They can very easily
forget their roots
as risk takers and innovators.
They can become risk averse.
They can focus on
maximizing profit above all.
They sometimes lack vision.
They sometimes-- their processes
become cumbersome and slow.
And they can ignore the
importance of social purpose.
These are all things that
this group of merchants
learned over this
70 year period.
And that's when things
become ripe for disruption.
And that's when
you start to think
about how appealing it
would be to find and develop
a New World.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, from
reading the book,
this took generations to happen.
And arguably, the more sort
of narrowly business focus
get rich quick ventures
failed one after the other
for various reasons.
JOHN BUTMAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: And finally, it took
groups with more cohesion--
a bigger purpose,
more social cohesion
and whatnot to finally succeed.
A lot of them with a
strong religious flavor--
eventually Massachusetts Bay
and others in New England.
So I got kind of a sense
that sort of just business,
or at least a narrow
focus was not sufficient.
What do you think about that?
JOHN BUTMAN: I think that's
absolutely right, yeah.
In fact, that's what I'm
saying about Jamestown
is that it took them a long time
to realize that you could not
send a group of soldiers
and sailors out who had no--
could not participate
in profit making
and had no say in what was
going on and expected to work.
It was just too top down.
It was too focused on these
profit making ventures.
And that's what happened
with the Frobisher,
the sort of gold rush.
So yeah, they
gradually said OK, we
have to allow people to
benefit from these ventures.
They have to have a
voice in the action.
So yeah, this idea of shared
purpose, social purpose
was really important and
totally essential to making
these business ventures work.
And when I say to people,
think about America
as a business startup.
This is very
disturbing to people
because it goes against this
whole idea of the Pilgrims
and tolerance and
our social purpose.
But the only point
is you need both.
And that's what they
learned in this period.
But yeah, that's a key point.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JOHN BUTMAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a
little more about the Pilgrims?
Like you said they were not
there for religious freedom
and it's all a myth.
What was the story
of the Pilgrims?
JOHN BUTMAN: Well,
so the Pilgrims,
they lived in
Holland for 10 years
and they had religious
freedom in Holland.
In fact, that was
not their problem.
They were very free to worship
in any way they wanted.
The issue was that they
were basically ex-pats,
they were strangers
in this society.
And they saw that
they could never
really climb the social scale.
So they worked in
menial jobs-- they
worked in the cloth industry,
there were some in publishing.
But they felt that they
weren't getting anywhere.
They also felt that they were
losing their cultural values.
So their kids, you know they
were there for 10 years.
And their kids started
to become very Dutch
and this was upsetting to them.
So they said, we're kind
of losing our identity.
They couldn't go
back to England.
They actually had other offers.
They got an offer from
the Dutch to settled
in New York, which sounded
like a pretty good deal.
But they rejected that when they
thought about moving elsewhere
in Europe.
But they finally made
this pretty bold decision
to come to America.
But the key point there is
that it wasn't a wilderness.
It wasn't like there
was nobody here.
There was a lot of
trade back and forth.
Jamestown was established.
They felt they could
easily get to Jamestown.
They actually wanted to--
they talked about settling
closer to Jamestown originally.
So that they-- for
the very reason,
they would have other people
to connect with, you know?
So it is a bold move,
there's no question.
But it wasn't about
religious freedom.
Plus, they didn't
have the cash to fund
themselves to hire a ship.
And that's why they had
a joint-stock company
behind them.
They made a very,
very bad deal that
required them to work seven
days a week until they paid back
the debt.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like with any
sort of business venture,
I'm curious whether after
the initial sort of success
of settling in the
Americas, was that sort
of like a huge bubble--
you know, an America bubble
which eventually burst?
And how did sort of the
ongoing investment dynamic
work after the initial
settlement and you know,
leading I guess, all the
way to the Revolutionary War
where I guess things
were disrupted?
JOHN BUTMAN: Yeah, so
two things happened.
One is that after the pilgrims
and after Jamestown found
tobacco, which was
their big product,
there was a bubble
of colonial activity
and not just from the English,
but also from the French
and from the Dutch.
So you see the Dutch in New
York and you see the French
in Canada.
And suddenly, all
these settlements
are coming in to New England.
So there's a lot of activity.
And the Pilgrims figured
out how to do fur trade.
So they were sustainable.
They didn't make a lot of money
but they were sustainable.
So yeah, suddenly
it was possible.
They knew how to do it.
They knew what you needed.
They knew how many people
you needed, how much money.
They figured out the
sort of fur trade
and they had a
lot of other ideas
for commerce that didn't work
out but fur was the basic one.
And they also went
back to fishing
because fishing was
a very reliable.
Fishing was great in New
England, especially in Maine.
So that's one thing.
But they also eventually
made it to the Far East.
So you see the English
starting to trade
to get to the Far East.
So now you've got
another source of income.
So the investors put together
basically a portfolio
of investment.
So they've got some
investments in America,
they've got some investments
in the Far East trade.
They're still selling in
to the continental markets
and they probably
own some fishing.
So they put together a
series of investments.
Some are high risk and
some are not so high risk.
So yeah, they start
to make money.
But the early ones really did
not make any money at all.
AUDIENCE: Do you think that
they'll ever sort of rewrite
the story of the Pilgrims so
that we can get it correct
and teach it correctly?
JOHN BUTMAN: Teach
our children--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHN BUTMAN: --well?
Well, that's our plan for
that our next book actually.
It's funny because the
literature about the Pilgrims
is quite interesting.
So the most recent one
is Nathaniel Philbrick
wrote a book called "Mayflower."
And he takes the
Pilgrims from 1620 up
through the King Philip's
War, which is 1675.
But he basically retells
the story as they told it.
Just saying this part of
it isn't so well known.
He doesn't really sort of
reframe it the way we have.
So it's interesting
because over the years,
especially in this
19th century period,
Pilgrims have become the vessel
to be filled with whatever
story you want to tell.
But I think it's really
important to retell it now
in this way because, to
me, it says a lot about how
we got to where we are.
So that's what we're
going to try to do, yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's
another thing that
struck me reading the book
is that this took generations
and it could have happened
almost 100 years earlier
with the right people and so on.
Do you think that's
true or did it really
need to take that long?
JOHN BUTMAN: Well, it certainly
could of because of the Spanish
were in the West Indies from
the beginning of you know,
1512 they go in to Mexico.
So it certainly
could have happened.
But the Spanish are
much better sea-goers.
They had better ships and they
had a very different attitude.
So it's the whole
big discussion here
is the relationship of Europeans
to local indigenous cultures.
And the Spanish basically just
went in and marauded and killed
and subjugated and took over
in the West Indies and Mexico
and South America.
And the English very,
very consciously
said, we don't want
to do it that way.
We want to behave differently.
And in fact, in his
early years, they did.
And although they did
kidnap Inuits and Indians
and bring them back
to England, they also
returned them to America.
And the relationship
was very different.
And they didn't really
have this religious purpose
that the Spanish had.
So yeah, it could
have been done.
But England was just-- they
were just really far behind.
Something about
England just hadn't
gotten there yet whereas the
Portuguese and the Spanish had.
But there's no reason--
I mean, America yeah, there's
no reason they couldn't have.
AUDIENCE: Of course
one could also
argue that the Spanish
and the Portuguese
did have one of those rare
get rich quick successes.
There was gold lying around.
JOHN BUTMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It might have--
JOHN BUTMAN: What's
intriguing though is if you
read about how it turned out--
in fact, having this enormous
stream of gold and silver
coming into Spain
ruined them basically.
Because King Philip said I
can prosecute any war I want.
I can do anything I want to.
Spent lots and lots of money--
they actually declared
bankruptcy at one point.
And it didn't do them
any good in the long run.
And the English--
it was good in a way
that they saw this example
and that they once sort of
said, let's go get this
gold mine didn't work.
And then they sort of
focused on other things.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]